[Applause]
well
before we dig in i saw that you posted
this on instagram and i actually
commented
on it and i started going down a rabbit
hole i've definitely had that moment
where i started a cleaning project
and suddenly got way too deep what
happened and the same
it's in a corner and i have to get to it
my husband's like when is it gonna
happen i'm like don't rush greatness
um yeah that's like the new like tired
thirst strap
being like i'm a re-conduing what are
you doing i have
learned on the show because we've had a
lot of
marie condo the home edit all these like
authorities
in this field and they all say start
small
they really do this is what happened to
me the other day i got into my jewelry
cabinet and went way too far ended up
crying my eyes out
that's a lot are those bracelets do you
wear everything
do you remember all what you have no and
i brought most of it here
to leave so that we could wear for the
show because i'm like i only wear
sweatpants and t-shirts at home so i
kind of
but i i bit way more than i could chew
i feel like i have to go back home and
fold laundry
truly but um and also like there is a
story i was really excited to talk about
with you
um which is that so apparently there's a
new syndrome
it's not fomo it's foda which
is in style reports that fotus stands
for
fear of dating again whoa and a lot of
singles are starting to get real sweaty
palms about resuming in-person dates and
experts want people to realize that
you're not alone everyone out there is a
little rusty as well
including your new date michelle
thoughts i think you have to be as
honest as possible you know we have been
home and quarantined for a really long
time and i think like get it
all out there don't even waste time
getting to know each other politely over
text
you know you went through so much
trouble just to meet for that coffee in
public right now
it's all got to mean something you know
what side of science are you on
you know do you have health insurance
what do you plan to
do did you finish your script you know
what i mean do you have to like sell
your car to make that music album
i can't we're not talking about me i'm
married but the point is
yeah i say get it all out there you know
just don't wait
don't wait you know what's interesting
michelle is this article
actually really backs that up and has
your same theory they talk about
honesty and when i heard you use those
examples some funny
some true some funny because it's true
it made me feel really comfortable with
the idea of honesty because it doesn't
have to be so heavy it can just be like
your fun
truths are you out there trying to wha
what's going on
you know i just closed my dating app
today actually
i had gotten on because i was like you
know why not
like let's try it yes and then i just
realized that i'm not ready
that's okay it will happen when you're
ready and sometimes you don't even know
you're ready do you know what i mean
everyone's in a rush
and for what nothing will make you edit
your plans like a pandemic like my
husband and i
love each other but at one point we were
talking to each other like we were
trying to talk to
alexa like not hearing a song yeah we're
like what
i can't hear you oh look at my husband
dead that was a very cute
he's dutch that's amsterdam you guys get
it oh i love amsterdam i love him and i
love you
okay your story is next very excited a
story where i could be the embedded
reporter
new scientist reports twins are at an
all-time high
i'm sorry all i do is twin twin twin
in the 80s there were nine sets of twins
born for every thousand
births and today there's 12 twins for
every thousand birds
that is three more i'm good at math
experts say it's because of ivf but also
women are having babies later
and as women age they're more likely to
release two eggs
at once that's a two for one so yeah i
mean
it's exciting i also feel like with this
knowledge that you know
shark tank and all these places that
make baby items
should keep that into consideration you
know and and
make stuff less expensive because i've
had to get two of everything with my
twins
you know that scene in um i love lucy
where like the chocolates on the
conveyor belt she's like
that's what it felt like for what year
is it for two years
yeah and they're two years old and so
sometimes i take pictures of them just
so i can remember what they look like or
even see what they look like and they're
starting
preschool or they're starting day care
in a few days
how does that milestone feel uh if for
them i
you know i think they'll love it for me
it feels
wow you know what i mean
like i haven't even been in a restaurant
i can't leave yelp reviews and now
i'm gonna drop my kids off to a place
i've never seen with people i've never
seen but you know what the good part is
is that i'm on tv so if anything happens
you gotta make it to drew's news
right here yeah we hold people account
to ball
um yes don't mess with my meatballs
speaking of meatballs what
what kind of segway is that that's the
segway i can get behind
huffpost reports that ikea the only
store that
that tires you out so bad you need a
tray of 25 meatballs ooh
and a dollar ice cream cone to recover
is offering a new plant ball
it's just like their famous swedish
meatballs but
it's made of plants guys every time we
say ball just take a sip of your coffee
now honey i don't know um if you know
this about me but i love me a meatball
party it's like
sort of my thanksgiving but i like my
friendsgiving yes everybody brings over
is it a meatball potluck it is we call
it swap meat and so we taste test
all the meatballs and if you don't bring
a ball you bring rose and it's just so
much fun and then like
we usually end up waltz working but
that's okay you know
i would love to like eat meatballs and
wall twerk with you
that's so funny you mentioned that
because we have meatballs right here
okay we can twerk
yes and we can twerk and we even have an
animation so you know it's a real party
that's
[Applause]
get right get it get it get it get it
get it
that music was very short but i still
hear it in my head i know
i it's a new music cue for us i i'm
excited
this is very exciting okay now we have a
a ball flight yes
yes i i um have um some jamaican jerk
chicken
um meatballs over here that you can
sample
and then my classic italian meatball
oh yeah oh my god that's good it's not
good
it's so moist and delicious now
i can't get plant balls not bad
nope i needed some berry sauce to go
with it
yeah now for the jerk chicken ball
oh it was spicy what's that nutmeg oh
it is nutmeg oh it's delicious
it's good so here's my feeling
about the ikea balls i think the ikea is
a really pleasant um texture it just
needs a little seasoning
well i what i wanted to do was dip the
plant bowl into your sauce
it's better already yeah night and day
yeah well sauce yeah it needed sauce
sometimes little slide little gravy
needle you know what i mean yes now it's
a little different
yeah and i wouldn't mind a toothpick
with it either i feel like
my teeth are like impacting by the day
and that's why more food keeps getting
stuck in there as soon as i
find out what that means i'm going to
agree with you
it's just i'm i'm just slowly dying
you